[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
cent onze noms de femmes qui ont été
victimes de féminisme interne
c'est-à-dire de féministes et rouge hugo
mais aussi dit non de travailleuses du
sexe qui ont été assassinés est
également le nom de céleste qui est une
jeune femme de 15 ans qui a été violée
et assassinée par un violeur
multirécidiviste quelques jours encore
une fois on voit que le gouvernement
fait des actes de communication mais
n'agit pas réellement ce qui a changé
depuis un an rien
nous on est toujours sur le terrain ce
qui a changé c'est que les voix c'est
libère aussi et qu'on refuse de se
laisser faire et qu'on continue à coller
tout simplement
[Musique]
tout est prêt